for a country known for its rain england
isn't seeing very much of it the
nation's water supply relies on places
like these a medley of reservoirs lakes
and underground stores they're kept
topped up by rainfall before it's
collected treated and then pumped into
our homes the uk uses around 14 billion
litres of water every day and out of
this
3.17 billion litres of water is lost
every day due to leaks over the next 20
years drier weather is forecast to
reduce supplies by around 600
million liters per day to keep an eye on
the uk's water supply we have to track
england's rainfall this is what we rely
on to replenish river and groundwater
levels this is what it looked like in
december last year the last time england
saw the expected amount of rainfall for
that month every month since has been
drier than expected but it's not yet as
severe as this june 2018 is one of the
driest summers on record as you can see
some parts of the country were more
affected than others central southern
and southeast england had the lowest
rainfall and it was so dry in the
northwest wildfires ripped through
grasslands here's what it looks like at
the moment the soil and reservoirs are
drier than normal because there hasn't
been enough rain over the past four
months river levels are exceptionally
low in these places the river north tyne
the mersey the y and froome
hot and dry conditions lead to drought
the uk assesses this in four stages all
of england except the northwest is
currently in that second category yellow
of prolonged dry weather if there is no
substantial rainfall soon we'd enter the
amber drought stage by august at amber
when water becomes scarce officials
start to take action the environment
agency begins to limit navigation for
boats in rivers and canals and the water
industry starts restricting
non-essential domestic and commercial
water use there'd be a visible
difference in major river levels
at its most severe drought holders will
come into force to control water usage
in certain areas the effects on wildlife
and farming would be catastrophic if no
preventative measures were taken and the
ground continued to heat up and we'd see
cracked land withered gardens and
parched reservoirs last seen in the
great drought of 1976. preserving the
uk's water levels is paramount although
water companies do have a sufficient
supply we have been told to use it
wisely